On Monday, January 3rd, a jury found Elizabeth
Holmes guilty on four criminal fraud charges.
They concluded she intentionally lied to investors
to raise heaps of money for her startup.
Theranos promised to revolutionize the healthcare
industry.
It claimed it could detect a wide range of
diseases with just a few drops of blood.
But it was all a lie.
And Holmes KNEW it, according to the jury.
Yet she continued to tout the technology.
Even convincing the likes of Oracle founder
Larry Ellison and media magnate Rupert Murdoch
to invest in Theranos.
At one point, Theranos was valued at $9 billion.
This is the story of how she managed to pull
it off and how it all fell apart.
Before Elizabeth Holmes headed off to Stanford
to study chemical engineering, her parents
gave her a copy of Marcus Aurelius’ “Meditations,”
in which the Roman emporer argued we each
have a purpose.
For many years, she fooled people into thinking
she was indeed living a purposeful life.
She dropped out of Stanford when she was 19
to build a device that she claimed could perform
hundreds of medical tests - everything from
cholesterol levels to cancer -- with a few
drops of blood from a finger prick.
She sold the dream of making the world a better
place by helping people diagnose diseases
WITHOUT the need to get their blood drawn.
She always appealed to ethos.
To me, nothing matters more than what people
go through when someone they love is found
out to be really, really sick.
She frequently cited the death of a beloved
uncle to skin cancer as the reason why her
faster, cheaper, and painless tests would
make blood testing a routine habit.
Who could resist such a story from a woman
who many compared to the late Apple CEO - not
only because they both had a penchant for
wearing black turtlenecks.
To me, it’s reasonable to compare you - I
usually don’t do this - to Steve Jobs.
I regard you as a visionary, next-generation
person.
Is this the kind of ridiculous pressure somebody
needs?
Steve Jobs was.
I don’t think there is another Steve Jobs.
He was a phenomenal entrepreneur.
We’ve got an incredible opportunity to try
to uphold a legacy in Silicon Valley of changing
the world.
Disrupting.
We’re working 24/7 to do that.
Well, I understand that’s exactly how you
work.
Everyone bought what she was selling.
It certainly helped that Holmes had a star-studded
Board to back her up.
Including former secretary of states Henry
Kissinger, George Shultz, former secretary
of defense William Perry, retired Marine Corps
four-star general James Mattis, former head
of the CDC William Foege, and former majority
leader of the U.S. Senate, Bill Frist.
It was only a matter of time before Holmes
started receiving glowing media attention.
Gracing cover after cover after cover.
Forbes labeled her the youngest self-made
female billionaire.
Holmes did everything she could to polish
her image.
Some say she even faked a deeper voice to
better fit into the male-dominated business
world.
In this interview from 2005, we hear Holmes
using a higher-pitched voice before appearing
to switch to a lower one.
Holmes checked off all the boxes to become
the darling of Silicon Valley.
She dropped out of a prestigious school.
She was young.
And secretive about her innovation.
In the world of tech, a certain mystique was
the norm, just like how Apple operated under
jobs.
She took investors’ money on the condition
that she wouldn’t have to reveal how Theranos’
technology worked.
No peer-reviewed scientific articles existed
to back up its claims.
Not everyone was so easily fooled, however.
John Carreyrou who was then a reporter at
the Wall Street Journal, exposed Theranos
for what it was in a series of articles in
2015 and later a best-selling book.
He reported that Theranos’ blood-testing
machine couldn't give accurate results, so
Theranos secretly ran its samples through
machines used by traditional blood-testing
companies.
Everything Holmes did was strategic, down
to the name of her company’s testing device.
Holmes named her machine Edison after Thomas
Edison, who famously said: "I have not failed.
I've just found 10,000 ways that won't work."
Holmes referenced Edison’s quote during
a commencement address at Pepperdine University
when she said: "We code-named our product
the Edison because we assumed we’d have
to fail 10,000 times to get it to work the
ten-thousand-and-first.
And we did."
(2015)
Except, they didn’t.
Walgreens reportedly brought Theranos tech
into its pharmacies without even testing the
technology.
The first patient to testify against Elizabeth
Holmes was Brittany Gould, who took a Theranos
test at a Walgreens, which revealed she was
miscarrying.
It would have been her fourth miscarriage.
To be safe, she decided to take tests at a
different clinic that confirmed she was, in
fact, still pregnant.
She eventually gave birth to a healthy baby
girl.
During the trial, Holmes’ lawyers argued
that it wasn’t she who was deceiving the
public but that she was herself deceived.
She claimed Theranos’ COO Sunny Balwani,
whom she had been dating, had manipulated
her.
But prosecutors weren’t buying it.
Prosecutor Jeff Schenk said in his closing
arguments: “She chose to be dishonest with
investors and patients.
That choice was not only callous, it was criminal.”
The jury agreed, finding her guilty on four
of 11 charges of fraud.
She faces up to 20 years in prison.
There is another company that you CAN get
behind and that brings me to the sponsor of
my video, Masterworks.
Masterworks lets you invest in multi-million
dollar artworks by artists such as Banksy,
Warhol, and Basquait by buying shares in their
paintings, just like you’d buy shares in,
say, Apple.
When Masterworks sells the art or you sell
your shares on their secondary market, the
returns can be enormous.
Masterworks returned 32% to investors when
they sold Banksy’s Mona Lisa in 2020.
The future of the art market is bright to
say the very least.
The art market is valued at $1.7 trillion
and Deloitte estimates that it could grow
another $900 billion by 2026.
Contemporary art outpaced the S&P in total
returns by 174% between 1995 to 2020, according
to publicly available data.
And with the way the stock market has been
reacting lately, why not diversify your portfolio
with one of the most stable assets around?
If you want to take advantage and invest in
some fine art, there is usually a waitlist.
However, you can skip that waitlist and immediately
start investing by clicking my custom link
in the description.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.